I hate and love telling people that they
got the Congress they voted for nobody
understands how the sausage is made
civic groups concerned citizens
organizations that kind of have a kind
of a schoolhouse rock understanding of
how the system works and I run into this
constantly I wouldn't we're going to
have to go back to the foundations of
the American Congress and try and
understand what it is that the founding
fathers were attempting to accomplish in
designing a legislative institution
everything in American civic life hinges
on understanding that we need to talk
about what power Congress is supposed to
exercise
Congress is the great thing the first
step in in government is to make a law
now in one sense this is fairly
straightforward the Constitution tells
us legislative power shall be vested in
a Congress of the United States and a
law is a general rule made in advance
that means laws are in their nature
simple in general and not detailed with
a vast array of circumstances in every
college has a congress class but really
what what it does mostly is just kind of
accepts that the status quo is a given
[Music]
I'm dr. Kevin Porteous professor of
politics at Hillsdale College and in
this series we'll be talking about the
development of the American Congress and
how it got to the point that it's at
today okay
so let's begin